foreign
protests are taking a violent turn of
the southern city of Guangzhou and one
video posted on social media people tear
down a covid-19 testing tent
in another protester's whole glass
bottles at police officers
moments later Security Forces dress in
hazmat suits Advanced information
holding protective Shields the Reuters
and AFP news agencies have verified the
videos were filmed in haiju District but
are unable to confirm when they were
taken or the sequence of events
hiju is where the bulk of China's recent
infections have been reported much of
the area has been under lockdown since
October the unrest marks an escalation
in a movement that spread to several
large cities from Shanghai and Beijing
to Chengdu and Wuhan I would say that
the Korean party actually underestimated
the anger at the Colossal level I I I I
would not think they are well prepared
for a protest uh occurring over the past
weekend the latest developments come
despite stern warnings against taking
part in demonstrations
in a statement China's top security
agency has called for a Crackdown on
what it says are hostile forces it's not
clear who or what the government is
referring to and is yet to provide
evidence of any external interference
it's also reiterated confidence in its
approach to the virus
fats over the years have fully proven
that China's covet protocols have
protected the security and health of the
Chinese people to the greatest extent
and minimized impact on socioeconomic
development some countries have made
remarks on China recently these nations
have enough issues to deal with at home
we hope they would heed the voices and
interests of their own people instead of
pointing fingers at others meanwhile
authorities have begun easing
restrictions in some areas including
Zhengzhou home to the biggest iPhone
Factory in China reduced Mass testing
requirements and allowed more businesses
to reopen still demonstrators fear
possible retribution Beijing some people
have voiced support for the protesters
I can still work from home so the
lockdown hasn't affected me too much but
seeing them fighting for freedom I think
is very inspiring anger about the zero
covert policy has morphed with people
speaking out against censorship and what
they say is an overbearing government
Patrick fock Al Jazeera Hong Kong